when there's no real-world justification
for the policies of the president a
strategy that we're seeing in the Trump
era is just make up a real-world
justification in an interview with
MSNBC's Chris Matthews trump advisor
Kellyanne Conway cited the imaginary
Bowling Green massacre as an example of
a terrorist attack committed by refugees
which points to the need obviously for
Donald Trump's Muslim majority country
immigration ban unfortunately as the
word imaginary suggests there was no
such massacre this is just the best take
a look at this video of Kellyanne Conway
on MSNBC it's brand new information to
people that President Obama had a
six-month ban on the Iraqi refugee
program after two Iraqis came here to
this country were radicalized and they
were the master master mind behind the
bowling-green massacre you might see
what I know that's a good thing I
covered most people don't know that
because media didn't cover it because it
doesn't exist and never did I mean
what's next thanks to Paul Revere and
Hitler's cousin's mistress not as many
lives were lost on the day of the
bowling-green massacre than we otherwise
would have seen this is actual fake news
but people in glass houses should not
throw stones and it is the Trump
administration that is the primary
purveyor of completely fabricated
narratives this is one of those
alternative facts that Kellyanne Conway
was talking about and as you can see
like I've been saying alternative facts
are merely lies to be thorough to be
thorough what was Kellyanne Conway
wrongly referencing in that interview in
2011 there were two Iraqi refugees who
were arrested in Bowling Green Kentucky
on federal terrorism charges they were
suspected of plotting to send money and
weapons back home to Iraqi insurgents no
one was killed by refugees in Bowling
Green there was never a plan to kill
anybody in Bowling Green and there was
also no ban on Iraqi refugee admissions
afterward under the trump administration
Iraqi refugees admitted to the United
States in every month of President
Obama's presidency is this still a
victory for the Trump propaganda team
though because she got it out there that
there was a refugee terrorist attack in
the US she mentioned the media didn't
cover it of course the media didn't
cover it because it didn't exist but
lots of trumpets won't fact-check and
this could be still a win for the Trump
administration and again the problems
the constant lives of the Trump
administration are a problem but they
would be a far smaller problem if there
weren't millions of Trumpets that
believe them so yes Kellyanne Conway
making this up out of thin air but I
wonder if this still helps the Trump
administration in terms of what many
trumpets will believe send me your
thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
today's program is sponsored in part by
blue apron I have been cooking some of
the February blue apron recipes which
I'll tell you a little bit more about in
a second blue apron ships you along with
easy to follow instructions the exact
amount of each ingredient that's
necessary for the recipe so that you
don't end up with half of a green onion
leftover which ends up in the trash or
vegetables that you don't know how to
use and you end up throwing them out
this is such a great way to reduce waste
while trying out new recipes blue apron
doesn't repeat recipes for an entire
year and some of the recipes available
this month include food on noodle soup
with miso and soft-boiled eggs crispy
barramundi with quinoa and roasted
carrot salad and cashew chicken stir-fry
with Tango mandarins and jasmine rice
check out this week's menu get three
meals free along with free shipping if
you go to blue apron comm slash Pakman
cooking at home is great brings the
family together
cheaper than eating out great in a lot
of other ways as well you know exactly
what's going into your meal go to blue
apron comm slash Pakman first three
meals free along with free shipping